bonjour bienvenue sur canal tv
aujourd'hui nous allons voir dans une
leçon la partie tchèque l'ouverture
tchèque avec jean baptiste bonjour le
bâtiment hortefeux alors l'ouverture
tchèque qu'est ce que c'est que ça
encore
alors l'ouverture tchèque ouais c'est
maintenant qu'on connaît pas forcément
mais une ouverture qu'on rencontre quand
même assez fréquemment dans la pratique
des tournois
ça commence comme une pirc mais on va
voir assez vite que l'idée est un petit
peu différente
l'ouverture pire que c'est un jeu de un
autre flanc à des deux côtés on essaye
de de jouer un influent ancien ghetto
est de pousser les pions sur l'ale dame
un peu comme un peu comme un dragon par
exemple doit-on tchèque s'est un petit
peu différent on joue on joue beaucoup
ces 6 au troisième coup pour avoir ça
assez vite voir ça pour sortir la la
dame est sous terré à la poussée du pur
ou alors c'est un petit peu un petit peu
flou pour le moment mais vous allez voir
c'est une idée ma foi qui peut se
défendre et donc il faut être prêt
pourquoi tchèque s'est jouée par les
tchèques c'est ça l'idée ça devait être
jouée par les tchèques
ouais ça a dû être joué peut-être un
tournant en tchécoslovaquie vous tous
sortis c'est à l'ailé rock voilà ça va
cesser c'est souvent les explications
quand on a le nom d'un pays sur une
ouverture c'est que c'est ça a été jouée
soit par une équipe nationale dans un
tournoi soit soi par soi beaucoup dans
le même tournoi
voilà on va voir cette ouverture tchèque
après eux quatre des six donc là c'est
ce qu'on disait ça démarre comme une
pire qu on connait si c'est classique
alors on des cadres entre cavaliers m6
toujours pareil toujours une pire
possible
cavalli ses six essais 3 way calais c3
pardon et 3 6 et 6 donc c'est ce qu'on
disait voilà le plan c qui bouge alors
avec des idées
différentes alors la première étant de
libérer la dame
c'est l'idée principale de cette
ouverture libère la dame qui va pouvoir
sortir avec une petite diagonale
tranquille ici et puis aussi on contrôle
la case des 5,5 et on soutient le pur
bessin possible et en soutien le pousser
mais ça part bien sûr dire impossible et
ça qu'on soutient la poussée bessin qui
peut être un coup intéressant pour
gagner de l'espace ont veillé de
l'espace chasser le cavalier c3 pour
pouvoir manger le plus bas en quatre ans
pouvant manger le pion à catherine et
puis souvent après b5 on va avoir une
belle case pour le fou aussi puisque
voilà donc ça c'est quelque chose qui se
rapprocherait plus de la plaque à la
limite
oui voilà tout à fait donc là on peut
jouer du coude comme les noirs n'ont pas
réagi au centre on peut jouer le coup
alors 4 voilà donc en fait l'idée de
damas cinq
l'idée de sortir la dame en a 5 pour les
noirs c'est de préparer la poussée et 5
sans avoir à être défroqué après dé
prendre 5 déprendre 500 prend 2,8
voilà ici on n'aurait pas d'un prendra
évidemment
voilà donc eu l'idée c'est pousser un
gros 4 4 et un co logique 4 et
écologique voilà il ya eu deux
possibilités aussi pour empêcher le
groupe b 5 c'est de jouer à 4 va le voir
tout de suite voilà agathe c'est un
choix intéressant gens priaient dans une
nouvelle partie d'ailleurs et qui est
souple si on empêche b5 voilà on empêche
blé 5 et alors là les noirs peuvent
jouer le clasico e5 quand même puisque
si les blancs prennent en fait on a le
lit des classiques pour les noirs c'est
qu'après pions prend c'est ça hein là et
je pense qu'ils pourraient pas parce
qu'ils seraient des rockets ouais mais
on pourrait mettre le roi c'est cette
salle idée non ça peut pas être à
possibilités ça non j'aime j'aime pas
tellement ouais c'est bon c'est une
possibilité effectivement mais sa dame
prend des 8 / tu en prends un singe ou
autres variantes watts de prendre 5
simplement tout jouer damas cinq
peut-être aussi non là on parle donc des
progrès 5 des progrès 5 d'apprendre et
bien sûr donc des préenseignes mais si
on n'a pas le choix une info prendrait
comprendre d'apprendre vite parce que
l'on ferait dame prenait 8 3 rendez vite
et fous ses cadres ses quatre mois la c4
et on peut pas mettre le roi ses sept
comme tu le disais direction si on
arrive à mettre le roi ans et 7 c'est
une bonne affaire
c'est pas loin mais là y'a le pion
problème avec 9,7 ouais donc le bronze
et noir peuvent se venger sur le sur le
pied de 4
ici je m'en fous des 4 et puis jouer
touré fuite ce genre de choses c'est
possible aussi peut-être c'est pour ça
que les bleus vont bien c'est jouable ne
faut pas quoi sur
le saint qui joue aussi au 5 et jouer
ils font pas comprendre
oui cette position peut-être parce que
en fait donc on montre comment cette
possibilité donc alors dé prendre 5 ha
oui mais des preuves 35 d'en prendre des
8,3 prend des vides ont poussé quatre
avaient l'idée attention j'attaque le
point faible il faut contre-attaqué sans
doute on vrai ou faux b4 contre attaque
sur le cavaly ses trois essais le pion
aux 4 qui est en fait étant prise et si
les blancs protège s'obtient raison
stéphane effectivement sur des prêts à
52.5 le couffo brigade avec les débats
3e set
voilà on peut mettre le roi voilà la
main de maître le voilà oui tout à fait
un peu droit un set et après jouer il
faut aussi on joue la finale dans des
conditions favorables effectivement et
donc c'est pour ça que les blancs font
ça thème sera donc là les blancs ne faut
pas donc c'est important à avoir quand
même réussi pourquoi on le fait pas
parce que parfois c'est souvent il faut
quand même toujours l'envisager donc
alors eu cinq donc les blancs jouent
plutôt le coup car les trois lacs ou
tranquillement cavalière 3 et les
problèmes restent entiers pour les noirs
maintenant puisque menace cette fois ci
de prendre 5 c est de gagner le pion
cette fois on gagne le pion 5 avec un
temps voilà ça c'est différent fou g4
pour les noirs alors mal règles plus ou
moins le problème est parce que je cloud
voilà sur pu reprendre cinq qui ont par
là on est obligé de faire alors là si
les noirs prennent évidemment on fait
d'abord d'un programme et on a plus de
problème pour prendre le pion celle de
toi d'abord pour les noirs prendre le
quart livre iii toujours penser à ces
coûts intermédiaires tout simple bref
trois donc on reprend il à garder la
structure de pions intacte et apprêtée
prendre ça on peut dire que les blancs
d'oeufs petit avantage ils ont déjà la
paire de file ont un bel avantage ou un
bel avantage c'est la raison pour
laquelle le 5 est pas forcément un
conseiller c'est pas à cause de tes
prendre 5 mai sa cause de quadrillage
trois coups tout simple de développement
pose problème
donc c'est pour ça qu'à 4 me paraît être
une possibilité intéressante
tout à fait donc on peut regarder un peu
la suite par exemple ou c4 ont tout
simplement car les b 17 et la force de
leur part de flou davantage des espaces
et les blancs vont accroître encore
davantage en revanche g4g 4 la menace
tout simplement g5 et si lecavalier et
cie se bouge et bien tout simplement
cède 1.7 maths ça oblige à jouer des
gros matches six qui sont très passif
regardez on va jouer h4 non seulement
ces passifs et en plus ça va ça va
vraiment aider d'autres petits rock plus
tard parce que le coatch il s'est quand
même sérieusement affaiblie sans effets
puissants donc là les noirs sont déjà
dans une situation difficile
une partie de gide polga que vous
pourrez trouver dans toutes vos la loi
toubon manuelle ou au ps de donner
exactement voir on voit le suit à la
suite quand même h4 le g6 food et 2 donc
logiquement pas grave on veut faire le
grand roque pour avoir une vie une tour
en vis-à-vis de la dame de roquettes du
petit côté et puis on veut effectivement
activer la tour en d1 c'est être grand
roque fou g7 et a pris roi bien là on
consolide notre position parce que notre
europe n'est pas non plus parfait et le
petit rock alors à dschang et un bon
coup h5 donc pris d'essai de vous
propose déjà de faire rage projet 6 donc
sa force le coup j'ai 5
voilà qui rend il ya un énorme ici comme
un trou énorme et puis c'est même pire
que ça parce que la taxe va très vite à
la cause de fou projet c'est judith n'a
pas raté avec le style qui la
caractérise
très très méchant dire est caractérisée
ouais
qui la caractérise la taxe sur le rock
avec franges et 5h pranger scène je
prends le taxi sera dé la tourache me
protège ceux qui ont un fils qui file à
dam
donc on est si si les noirs jouent le
simple fou à schwyz pour tout simplement
on peut jouer h cet échec sur et sur
cavale et prend h7 est bien et seront
prêts regardez tout simplement tout
reprendre cavaliers ici pour dévier en
fait cette dame
l'idée c'est de dévier la dame et le
cavalier 17 surtout enfin pour éliminer
le cahier 17 qui pourrait venir assez
sombre et des mines et le défenseur à
l'aspirine défenseurs et après d'armes
prend 17 tout simplement damas trois et
regardez pas ce qu'on n'ose pas empêché
d'un proche 7 maths et derrière le x
suite mate aussi l'action honda
lecavalier parce que on peut pas jouer
le pion à vii qui serait une bonne idée
c'est de jouer 6 en 10 ans la dame
protège le cavalier mais regardez il ya
le fou c4 qui fait aussi échec au roi
donc c'est un match rapide donc
attention attention dans cette variante
possibilité de se prendre ma thérapie
donc on voit tous les problèmes que don
auxquels peuvent faire face les noirs
sur le coup vicieux à son profit cieux
ouais ouais c'est
vicieux ça prive les noirs de leur
expansion avec b5 donc c'est intéressant
et on va fois par exemple sur tab à 5 et
un cookie ici tout de suite
ouais non en fait ça tous cavaliers mais
on protège on protège avec le vous vous
fondez 3 tout simplement une position
tout à fait jouable alors tout à fait
intéressante alors on voit l'autre idf 4
alors ça c'est le coût principal voilà
c'est plus ambitieux parce qu'on veut
essayer de jouer ça que nous mêmes aussi
voilà ont réussi de prendre une grosse
expansion centre avait que 5 et donc
donc les noirs vont réaliser leurs idées
damas 5 et là on a deux possibilités
claque ça cool kbc 3 donc en k 2 5
on pourra jouer cavalier en d5 voir
cavaliers ans le 4 2 possibilités soit
on protège notre pions soit on pousse là
on peut aussi devant la poussée
peut-être et sur cinq ans veut le voir
tout de suite c'est très intéressant
alors sur cavalier e 4 donc on voit un
profit du cavaly ces trois kits loué à
la dame à 5 forêt et chaque jour on ne
peut pas bouger ce cavalier
donc on en profite pour le pour rajouter
une pression sur ce qui avait un secret
le cas très bien morose et vise à donner
une idée intéressante tes fans ces deux
non pas de protéger le cavalier c3 qui
serait un petit peu trop passif et
développer la pièce sur food et 2 peut
être comparée à la perte de fou sans
grande compensation donc eh bien on
continue le développement et on laisse
les noirs se débrouiller avec leurs deux
pièces sorties seulement dont la dame ce
qu'est point trop conseiller ils ont des
pions pour le développement on n'a pas
peur dans six mois veulent bien les
prendre
oui on va les donner mais ce n'est même
pas sûr parce que sur cavaliers prend
ses 3 puis en france et 3 on imagine une
position par exemple après d'armes
français 3 imaginons d'un prince et
renvoie là et bien j'aurai fou d2 où va
la dame à 3 n'a pas de casino mais
surtout déjà c'est déjà dangereux quand
la dame a pas beaucoup de cannes oui
alors on voit pas l'enfermer et on ya
encore des encore certaines cases mais
c'est vrai que c'est délicat déjà et
puis on peut je me fous des trois pour
continuer le développement social adam
street
on a donné un pion mais pour un
développement très très rapide d'alcool
nb pour dans la roue ne tourne à une
perte de fou
mais ici on va pouvoir mettre une
colonie si on va pouvoir roke est donc
la poussée f5 voir avec 6 plus tard six
ans après l'histoire et pour seulement
un pion pour seulement un petit pion on
a un très bon jeu faut pas hésiter aux
échecs un lâche et un pion à l'ouverture
si vous c'est accélère le développement
laisser l'adversaire prendre vos pions
et vous vous prendrez le roi ouais il
n'y a pas de règle générale là dessus
mais on peut dire quand même que pour un
pion quand on a trois pièces mineurs de
2 de la lgv en soin de développer comme
d'une grille est effectivement bien que
trois pièces pour un pion ça vaut
largement hors jeu normalement t'es pas
de règles mais si on veut vraiment se
rattacher à quelque chose de trois
pièces développées pour notre pays
développés pour pour un pion c'est bon
c'est une bonne affaire
bonne affaire et si vous jouez en tout 2
c'est borderline mais trois semaines
normalement c'est une bonne affaire
c'est une bonne affaire en jeu un tout
petit peu agressif et l'affairé est dans
le sac
voilà faut pas mollir par contre
effectivement là il faut pas faux pas
après jouer petit bras mais il faut
créer des menaces concrètes après donc
damas 5
donc là on vient de voir le coup cette
première possibilité aussi un conte à
pondre on a intérêt d'être un pion donne
le pion c3 n'a pas de points on laisse
les noirs perdre du temps
l'autre approche c'est de conserver le
centre et une approche un peu plus
positionnelle et de conservation souple
donc on garde une souplesse ils savaient
qu'ils ont donc on pourra jouer choisir
joué cinq dessins kiev 5 plus tard en
fonction des possibilités on joue
tranquille et là les noirs jouent leurs
idées principales dans cette ouverture c
e 5 voilà maintenant il joue 5
tout à l'heure on voyait que c'était pas
trop l'idée parce qu'on pouvait prendre
vous pouvez changer les dames il ya tout
un tas de problèmes
là maintenant que la dame étant à cinq
il ya plus probable des changes de dames
et on protège la case de 5
voilà et donc sur un double échange
entre 5 et blanc trouvé qu'un pion et
isolée en surprises ici prise d'ici
imaginons qu'ils aient encore une prise
les noirs prendrait en 5 sans doute sans
doute
et voilà il ya un pion aux 4 qui
centrale mais isolé il ya la radio les
mêmes pour bloquer un peu isolé au dic
fois une pièce milliards dont peut-être
mieux d'en prendre 5 encore on peut
faire cavalier 4 avec l'idée de
reprendre le pion aux 5 très affaibli
avec lecavalier avec le cavalier encore
plus fort sachant que le coût de 6
espérant des structures et espérant des
structures il ne marche pas commencé
mollement on prend du fou voilà donc à
noter quand même 7 ses possibilités donc
sur cinq les blancs ne rentrent pas dans
cette évidence et variantes mais
continue lentement thaler voilà toujours
dit consolident leur sang qui arrivent
tous vos classiques alors que chicago
sortez vos pièces le plus vite possible
n'ayez pas peur d'eux de fait surtout ne
perdez pas de temps à jouer trop les
pions si vous avez une position centrale
comme ça de développer donc fou g4 c'est
logique au c1 c'est logique le cavalier
f3 était sorti pour défendre le plan des
cadres donc fouillé 4 vient clouer ce
cavalier donc c'est un coup de dé
veloppement tout à fait logique
une autre possibilité qu'on peut
peut-être regarder rapidement c'était le
coup cavale et b17 au lieu de fuji
quatre ont joué le coup cavalli b oui
parce que quand on joue au foot j'ai 4
il faut être sûr que les blancs ont
donné vont jouer h3 et vont nous
demander de perdre un pion et de pardon
prendre le temps de printemps sur le fou
il va falloir même l'échangé donc
toujours fous j'ai cassé pour s'échanger
contre le père liège trois points ça
c'est sûr si on n'a pas envie de soigner
ce foulard peut jouer qu'avec 17 mai
c'est un peu plus passifs et sur un jeu
simple et bien on peut jouer par exemple
le petit rock alors qu'elles sont par
exemple plus très simplement petit rock
faut être fou et 7 pour les noirs donc
ça c'est classique alors roche un
crachat toujours vite voilà on est vite
parce que si on veut être tranquille il
faut éviter des coûts après comme dame b
si ce qui pourrait prendre le pion b26
on joue phocéen et avec un échec ici
comme symbole on a joué 4 c'est bien de
mettre le roi tient toujours le bienvenu
un abri mais il va aussi et là
maintenant on va pas profiter de notre
avantage des espaces pour déployer une
attaque puisque les noirs ont plus de
mal à se défendre
manquant des espaces donc damien alors
damon il ya ce genre de menaces qu'il
faut pas oublier jean baptisé oui c'est
un peu un classique par exemple
imaginons que les noirs jouent le coup à
b5 qui est possible ont joué le coup
cavaliers dessin croire dès ce superbe
coup le cal est en prise mais mais mais
regardez la dame un attaque la dame à
senghor ça c'est un coup classique il
faut connaître parce que si les noirs
prennent la dame
aïe il ya un coût intermédiaires qu'il
faut absolument connaître tout
simplement prend d'abord le cavalier le
fou en 7 avec échec
donc il
jouer le roi est maintenant 5e la pièce
on récupère la pièce rock pas d'âme et
on a une pièce davance voilà piège
extrêmement classique on va barder en
plus le cavaly mène en attaque le pion
sait si c'est quand les noirs je vous
fous mais c'est tout simplement ressort
à 9,5 pour gagner une pièce net 1
d'ailleurs la suite de la partie après
dames 1
on va montrer le thème que tu viens de
nous présenter avec surprendre et 4 peut
prendre des quatre est bien le joueur
qu'il est blanc ici qui est beau logan
ne va pas reprendre le plan des caves et
fabriques cahier de d5 forçant la dame
noire à revenir en des huit la dame donc
la noix d'avoir de grands pas ont pas
bien sinon on perd 10 compères le pion
le fou et donc on joue d'amener 8
voilà cavaliers prend 1,7 et on prend la
paire de fou on prend la perte de fruits
on va voir que c'est plus que des
principes c'est grave puisque des cases
noires sont très affaiblis maintenant
donc la dame h4 voilà la demoiselle
adams était cloué le cavaly m6 est cloué
poste de la dame cette maladie qui peut
pas bouger puisqu'il adams être en prise
sur calais des cinq qui protège la dame
en proposant en échange simplement on
prendrait un cavalier puisque la dame h4
est protégé par le cabinet 3 eh bien ce
n'est pas poussé aux cinq par exemple on
peut menacer la poussée aux cinq
regarder avec le fou détroit qui
attaquent h7
il y aurait échec au roi lecavalier 6
pourrait toujours pas prend puisque la
dame cette emprise exactement bons
soucis donc sur damas quatre on sera
obligé de jouer à 6 voilà mais là on
voit comment jouer au sein quand même 5
parce qu'on a tout de pièces qui sont
bien placés pour attaquer c'est vrai à
ouvrir les lignes des 335 f3 5-5 et la
toro enlever la fera mal tout simplement
tour ou un clouage du cavalier de saint
quihouët avérée non avec beaucoup avec
beaucoup d'attaquants mais beaucoup d'
attaque on peut aussi envisager jean
baptiste le l'évidence il faut prendre
ce risque a l'air très fort en évidence
oui enfin les vétérans intéressant ce
dos évidemment tout cas il ya une grosse
attaque il ya toujours une grosse
attaque parce que si les noirs prennent
le cadastre on peut prendre de la tour
et c'est la tour qui ramène aussi qui se
ramène à l'attack et si on prend le fou
eh bien on a fait quand même une belle
opération
tout simplement on peut faire cavaler
prendre 5 et regarder la tour et la dame
attaque le quart à m6 et le roi reste
très faible
le roi reste en tout cas c'est pas
anormal que dans une position toutes nos
pièces sont brad est comme ça vers un
même secteur de l'échiquier on est des
possibilités comme fo prend 1,6 donc
attention voilà donc voilà cette
variante qu'on a vu sur calais b 17
on vient de le voir après cette superbe
possibilité d'attaquer en jouant petit
rock roy chain et la dame ici d un qui
vient à eux 1 avec cette idée toujours
classique câbles et des cinq ce
vis-à-vis d'am-dam qu'on va retrouver
dans d'autres ouvertures par exemple la
variante du dragon oui ça existe aussi
raconte la sicilienne alors faudra voir
l'autre coup vous éclater quand même
préférable rouge est 4ème à faire donc
là on continue le développement fouet
trois voix là parce que notre plan des
quatre étaient menacés à cause du cloud
âge donc voila voila il va être
maintenant ya pas mal de possibilités
donc là il ya trois possibilités soit
les noirs peuvent prendre en d4 soit il
joue encore kamel et b17 en f4 j'aime
j'aime pas trop que olive et 17 pour par
une poutre au point de décision samba
parce que maintenant sur h3 faut prendre
trois est obligé d'en prendre trois et
on voit on a quand même un avantage
écrasant puisqu'on a beaucoup d'espacé à
la perdre le fouet en font réagir en
donc on va voir peut prendre des quatre
voies la reprendre des quatre ici donc
les noirs réagissent au centre tout de
suite donc là il faut prendre vie
d'avant et tout simplement d'un v4
attaque le fou des quatre indirectement
je dirais après faut prendre trois en
tout cas d'un b 4 avec l'idée que
j'attaque à la fois le fou des 4es de
pure mais deux puisque je menace fou
prend cavaliers et après d'en prendre le
fou des 4es perdu donc le fou des cartes
est aussi le pion d2 donc là les blancs
jouent leur jeu barras de personnes pour
attaquer food prize 6 voilà simplement
par là dedans c'est un échange
gêné par m6 et maintenant le simple
dames des deux dames d2 puisque sur tam
prend b2 maintenant cavalier c3 serait
protégé d'un prendre b2 ont joué tout
simplement tourbe et un tour bien et on
récupère un peu un vieux pont bill 7
avec avec avantage puisque cette
structure là est très mauvaise pour les
noirs garder les trous qui a on va pas
pouvoir faire le petit rock et après la
prise en baisse est le grand roque non
plus donc les noirs on prend une grosse
attaque qui a fait le point des quatre
bon c'est pas trois conseillers pas
terrible on peut regarder le problème
quatre peut-être alors on peut regarder
eux prend un f4 l'entreprise donc il
faut prendre f4 prend un f4 dame b 6
donc la même idée d'un v6 j'attaque
cette fois non plus le fou en égal mais
le pion on écarte puisque je menacerait
faut prendre cavaliers suivi de d'en
prendre quatre et j'attaque au site le
pion ou alors on est dans une suite
intéressante
on va essayer de jouer cette position
comme shirov la jouer et on joue
d'hommes des deux cavaliers de cavaliers
de cavaliers de malades alors très
intéressant d'abord je défends le
cavalier des quatre jeux des clous ont
passage le câble est vraiment qui
devient actif puisqu'il défend vraiment
on écarte aussi est aussi la classe de
seine où est ce que je voulais dire
c'est que tan des deux était moins bon
des femmes absurde parce que je prends
f3 là on perdait le pion des cases donc
c'est pas c'est pas le plan b 2 que les
noirs prennent si on était sûr que les
noirs prenez le pion de b2 ce serait
bien et là ça serait le théâtre tient
sans tralala ça serait ça serait pas une
bonne affaire le plan b 2 c'est vrai
qu'on s'en sort bien mais on joue
cavalier de jouer le malin cariou de
avec l'idée aussi que l'option ces deux
pourra venir à maintenant protéger aussi
plaints des 4 on a libéré les oiseaux
noirs quelques en protège bien le plan
des 4 est maintenant le seul moyen
justifié je dirais le ku'damm v6c
d'encaisser le pion le plan b 2 mais
c'est très dangereux
voilà sicile et noir prennent en d2 ici
tout simplement les blancs
continueraient leur développement sans
doute oui on se pense qu'il faut se
développer durablement et bardi asia
tour b1 qui va venir avec le pion
bessette derrière donc alors difficile
et puis y'a rien le cou aux cinq surtout
aussi qui va venir aux 601 août avec des
belles possibilités aussi dans la partie
je dors cheer up en fait c'est comme
s'il a pris l'option b 2000 a pris
d'abord en f3 mais a pris d'abord en f3
voilà j'ai pris un f3 dame prend b2
maintenant on prend quand même b2 et là
tout simplement tourbillon tout de suite
voilà la tour donc il grave les pions
les noirs bon c'est souvent des pions
pas sonné tout ça puisque là après on
prend bessette et les noirs ont déjà des
gros soucis
ah oui il ya le roi qu'ils ressentent et
un avantage de développement la dame en
a deux qui étaient pas très bien placé
souvent c'est dallas font prendre
parfois elles se font enfermer donc il
faut être très très attentif
c'est pourquoi
les noirs propose le coup damas un échec
pour revenir pour revenir par exemple en
défense on évite tout simplement fou des
deux attaques la dame d'amd vite hélas
très joli coup de girofle dans cette
variante c'est le ku'damm un ouais donc
très actif puisque je perds pas de temps
je contrôle les cases noires donc
pourquoi pas pour envisager les coups
comme 5 voilà il ya surtout un enduit
j'attaque à 7 10 avril +1 7 milliard
surtout un petit truc marrant c'est fou
à 5 aussi et il ya aussi la mauvaise
passe quand on s'en prend à la dame
noire et elle va où la dame
oui parce qu'elle a plus beaucoup
avancer vite on jouerait tour c'est cet
état serait obligé de revenir après sur
des cases un petit peu on pourrait
envisager
imaginons un coup comme h 6,5 ou bidons
regarder la possibilité de jouer par
exemple fois cinq voix d'avancé 8 et
elle pourrait encore venir
3 enfin déjà la dame est mal placé mais
peut être que dame b 2 quand même
atteint ici intéressant puisque là on
menace est cette fois-ci ici la dame
sans vote dame b cette voie la tour c
'est djellabi piqué la tour à voir sur
place d'un mais tours qui vont attaquer
donc avec gros avantage donc enlevé très
joli coup de main sur demain avec des
idées multiples et bien le seul coup de
défense de jouer à 5 pour les pour les
noirs à 5
voilà pour empêcher ces variantes là
mais on voit déjà le pion à 5 y est
faible il déjà attaqué alors on protège
ses réponses à manger le pion à
contrôler la casa 5 mai en tout cas
c'est le seul coup et l'assurance met le
doigt là où ça fait mal puisqu'il fut
des 5
l'idée maintenant c'est que ce fou
détroit va y accueillons ces six qui
défend les cases blanches auraient donc
elle va vouloir en faire un échec
mortels ici puisque le roi a pas de cas
le roi noir et au centre donc on ouvre
les lignes alors que notre roi blanc
aussi honnête mais nous on a toutes les
pièces développées donc presque à la
tourache entraîne encore un peu mais ça
ne saurait tarder donc des cinq états
coup logique d'ouverture de ligne est
sûre alors sur pions prend des cinq
bombes
après faut surprendre des 5 qui serait
une grosse faute sans doute enfin tout
cas c'est pas logique surtout sur foot
b5
on commencerait à avoir un petit peu de
jeu quand même sur les scènes qui a pas
beaucoup de l'an dernier
il faudrait jouer un coup comme cavalier
f17 très passif selon aussi vite et on
peut aussi tout simplement reprendre
ouais pas suffi puisque les et noir ne
peuvent pas reprendre le pion là parce
que la foulée cinq gars d'une pièce
devrait jouer calais 17 et on prend le
comprendre cavaliers ont des problèmes
de colonne aussi pour attaquer donc de
prendre des cinq miens aussi je crois
qu'on peut arrêter là pour s'en aller
plus loin ouais une position agréable à
jouer pour les blancs de position en
attaque
tout est sorti on va sans doute faire le
petit rock rapide ouais faut pas ma part
de faire de petits rock éventuellement
de doubler les tours sur la colonne b
voilà par exemple quand même beaucoup de
choses à jouer ici avec une attaque
possible les noirs peuvent encore s'en
sortir mais il faut jouer très serré un
ouais je vais très très serré donc je
crois qu'on a fait tout voilà la
résidence on va dire trois possibilités
comme musique pôle gare par exemple
qu'avec à 4 comme morose et beach
on joue e5 très vite ou alors ce que
shirov à jouer c'est à dire protéger le
centre en sortant les deux cavaliers les
deux fous et au moment opportun ouvrir
les lignes puisque les les noirs ont
joué de manière un petit peu original en
son temps la dame un peu trop vite et
profiter de la faiblesse du roi au
centre et ce qui est intéressant aussi
dans cette dans ce type d'ouverture
comme ça un peu secondaire c'est qu'on
va retrouver des thèmes généraux qui
sont applicables dans les autres
ouvertures comme comme souvent comme
souvent la danse tous ces thèmes ou si
c'est pas que l'ouverture en tant que
tel qui est important c'est tous les
principes qu'on vous a donné le principe
de donner des pions pour l'attack de pas
hésité à accélérer son développement au
prix d'un pion voilà il ya toujours
déséquilibre qu'il faut connaître comme
ça ce n'est qu'un pion contre le
développement
ça c'est le dynamisme vous bien le
dynamisme voilà et donc trois
possibilités sur ce warrant tchèque
reprenez la leçon doucement
et vous aurez un choix à faire il ya
poseurs plusieurs bons choix
la balle est dans votre camp voilà
c'était la défense tchèque sur lionel tv
avec jean baptiste merci l'artiste
à bientôt au revoir